all right gentlemen we're not even
talking about conspiracy theories
anymore we are just talking about
scientific facts okay cuz please
gentlemen explain to me the Mandela
effects which is the phenomenon the
phenomenon Theory okay okay that's uh
named after Nelson Mandela the theory
suggests that Collective false memories
why is it named after Nelson Mandel
because it started off with the theory
that Nelson Mandela died in prison yeah
oh when he actually did yeah and it's
it's it's a collective right or
something like that right yeah the core
the core of it is that it is a
collective false memory that Society has
about certain things you know yeah like
how everybody remembers something
looking a specific way when in actuality
everyone's remembering it all the same
but it's all wrong is it like how like
everyone thinks that like an uh
Invincible he says think Mark think but
he just says think or stss how he says
thinks it's Luke I am your father but he
just says no I am your father and this
is objective proof that ultimate
universes exist this is this is this is
objective proof that on multiple
parallel universes exist so what you're
saying is there is a parallel universe
out there where Nelson Mandela actually
died in prison yes and our Collective
Consciousness remembering the split
sometimes splits off and sometimes you
have false memories of a universe that
did not exist this is some steinsgate
[__] right here it is it is so we all
have memories of this other universe is
what you're saying yeah or or the other
universe is seeping into our Collective
Consciousness could you give me some
examples of stuff that might convince me
I'd love to hear more about this Theory
okay so there we've you know we've
talked about the line uh we've talked
about Lon Mandela uh the Monopoly man as
well is something that I remember oh
yeah the Monopoly man having a mustache
is a monocle oh a monocle sorry yeah he
has he has a mustache he
doesn't he has a mustache right pull up
the Monopoly man pull him up what's the
Monopoly man look like no no no the I'm
pretty sure the Monopoly man doesn't
have Monopoly okay let's pull up the
Monopoly man I just want see he's he's
got a [__] mustache oh he doesn't
have a mon it's a monocle it's a mon
well he well wait doesn't he in some of
the cards or am I crazy no no he never
had he never had a mon but I okay I I
can explain this one uh I think because
then yeah obviously Monopoly is such a a
well-known thing in Western culture sure
I think a lot of uh parodies or kind of
uh reimaginings of the Monopoly man
whenever it's used in media will haveen
with the monocle it just seems natural
so then I think then we apply the
monocle to our memory of the caricature
of the Monopoly man right right so I
think that's why we envision him having
I think that's how a lot of the Nelson
Mandela effect stuff happens is that
like we take other facts
because this app to yeah because if you
were to dress up in a Monopoly man
outfit parody esque you would naturally
add a monol CU it would tie the outfit
together to parody it right so I think
that's why this one is kind of caught
on um uh are there other examples of
Mandela effects I'm looking at them
right now yeah uh let's see what else
what else do we have oh the baren stain
Bears this is very popular one in
America we don't have this in the or
Australia Americans have these these
Bears Curious George what about it he
doesn't have a tail I know that who's
Curious George what the [__] do youan
what the [__] do you mean who oh the
monkey everybody remembers Curious
George having a tail but he doesn't have
a tail okay I didn't grow up with kir
George so I don't remember him having a
tail so I know he never had a tail okay
uh let's see what else is there a lot of
these are American yeah most like cuz
they have the um in America they have
the uh in the car mirror yeah they have
the objects appear Loop Closer Than They
objects in Mirror are closer than they
appear yeah but that's not what it says
says something else but everyone
remembers it as that yeah or like fro
Loops what about fro Loops like
everybody remembers fruit being spelled
like f r UI T and then Loops l o o PS
right it's f r o o t yeah it's f r o o t
well I'm not American so I know that
one I know that monop man his monocle
Pikachu's tail you has a tail no no no
though many of us clearly remember black
detailing on the Pokémon character's
tail but in reality it's just yellow no
he's a brown on it at one point no oh on
the base on the
base everybody everybody remembers like
a black thing on the Ed of no no it's on
the Basse yeah yeah there's a brown
thing on the base you just [__] dumb
if you think if you like mess remember
that yeah well some people remember it
no there not no uh KitKat uh having a
hyphen uh no it's never had a hyphen
never had a hyphen KitKat it's always
been one word or yeah one word on the
packaging people remember KitKat having
a hyphen it's Kit hyphen cat I think I
think I might have been one of those
people that F that yeah it doesn't it's
never had a hyphen oh [__] okay
okay yeah the I think I think Nelson
Mandela the the Mandela effect to me is
just a very interesting case study of
like kind of like Mass psychology you
how we perceive events and how we
perceive
information um we can you know there are
some certain things in let's say history
that people just perceive the same way
um I mean fro like if someone like Peete
can think harambe died of natural causes
you know and just perceive that as an
event the greatest conspiracy theory I
would like to the greatest conspiracy
theory you know I do not doubt that we
as a group kind of like Collective can
perceive certain events in certain ways
or have certain memories that a lot of
the times oh yeah a lot of fuckups can
be explained by the fact that we are
terrible at remembering this we are just
bad at that here's an interesting one
jaw Jaws right when the the scene we've
all seen Jaws right no okay but we all
know the scene where he's throwing the
chum into the thing and the thing
appears and he says that line what does
he say we're going to need a bigger boat
he doesn't say that he says you're going
to need a bigger boat oh oh I believe
that that's another one everybody thinks
it's we going to need a bigger boat how
is that like a Smoking Gun you know what
I mean it's
like um okay you're going to going to
need a bigger boat um I yeah I I think
oh Snow White she never says mirror
mirror on the wall oh I don't know that
what does she say she says magic mirror
on the wall okay well sh not she not
good is it y we made the quote better
yeah also this is we fixed Snow White
there's examples of this where like um
with lost media for example like there
are some real cases where lost media is
lost media there are some where people
collectively online are like hey did you
guys ever hear about this game or this
movie I watched as a kid where this
thing happened and everyone's like oh
yeah I think I did watch that is it
where this happened too and they're like
I think that happened yeah and then
everyone starts piecing this in and
they're just making up something that
didn't exist because you know our
memories are very fractured and we don't
remember things as they as they I'm sure
you have so many memories of kids of
very brief moments of something that you
can't piece together but you're like I
remember this detail oh yeah for sure I
think that that that kind of stuff can
can the interesting thing about the
Mandela fact is that it's not just one
person who thinks this it's many many
many people thinking exact same detail
that is just incorrect to play Devil's
Advocate okay parallel
universes I forgot this was the the
that's the main core concept of this ARG
okay sure do you believe that parallel
universes exist yes wow I've seen
Stein's gate so yes no you don't believe
they exist no why not just don't just
don't think they do I seems like a I
don't know a lot of effort I've never
thought about it enough to know whether
I believe in it or not there's there's
actually like a theory that could have
parallel universes as like a uh you know
as an explanation so there's a there's a
theory that's gone around which is you
know in are you building a theory on top
of a theory now yeah yeah yeah a theory
Theory so this is this is what
scientists have observed when it comes
to like quantum mechanics uh which is
you know you can never fully predict how
a um you can never like fully predict
what's going to happen with Quantum
quantum theory until like a waveform
collapses right yeah cuz you think about
the uh was it the [__] cat thing
Shing his cat rooing is C thing which is
I'm I'm not going to I'm not going to
comment on the exact the it's the
uncertainty principle the uncertainty
principle I'm not going to comment on
the exact mechanics of it but what I do
know is that you know scientists cannot
explain why quantum mechanics acts the
way it does it's the isn't it the theory
that it's like if there if something has
two outcomes that it could be one of
them is the one that we see and then the
other one is the one that's in the
reality in the parallel universe yeah
one the the theory is that when
scientist observes on a Quantum level
and it collapses into one of like two
possibilities that that's when the creat
parall universe that's when the universe
branches off that'd be [__] cool
wouldn't it cuz then there's a universe
where I can do cool [__] but this it's
not
true unfortunately I'm very uncool one
one sentence that I hate hearing in like
it's fine now but in like day-to-day
conversation people tell me this like
they're like scientists can't explain
I'm like hold on now that's like that's
such a blanket statement to throw out
there like all scientists have gone well
guys none of us can none of us can
explain it I guess uh we should just
quit like it's done yeah also it's it's
like admitting that like it's like an
easy way to just say this this thing is
beyond your understanding it's like well
okay I feel like there's a lot more
Nuance to every situation here also I
think like you know the that whole
phrasing of scientists can't explain
scientists are not supposed to explain
they're supposed to make it easier to
explain but they're not the on who are
supposed to be like so this is exactly
how it is because we saw it and we you
know measure it and everything like that
no like they just building theories on
top of theories on top of theories until
we eventually get to something that
everyone can agree is the trth it's
iterative it takes time you know I think
maybe doesn't necessarily mean that it's
you know that it's never going to be
explained yeah yeah um but I do believe
in parallel universes uh unironically
unironically yeah I think ially believe
in it as well I think just it it it's a
convenient yes it is a convenient way to
explain a lot of inexplicable things
that are happening right now that we're
observing but it's also just a cool idea
you know well it's sick idea I just
don't buyck idea it's a cool idea but
also I believe like you know cuz I've
been getting deep into like the whole
kind of like physics side of things of
like higher Dimensions um and it just
seems to me like all of our science kind
of breaks down when we get to like the
quantum level yeah there is so much that
just does not make sense logically in
our brains when you go down to like that
level and it's you know conceptually
parallel universes where everything
happens all at once whatever you know
that's cool from a story perspective but
like even even like more simple stuff
like why does time move the direction it
does know why why does time move
forwards you know you think you think
that it makes sense on a conceptual
level when we think about this universe
uh but if you go to like the quantum
level uh I believe there's no actually
there's no actual proof of why time
needs to move in the direction it does
you know um same thing with kind of like
entropy which is the kind of like idea
that's saying big words now go yeah the
chaos right the idea that Chaos Theory
yeah kind of like everything moves to
like energy move from disorder to order
or it might be the other way around I
think G and I have been watching the
same videos recently cuz this is this is
all the [__] I've been watching as well
this is too much yeah and and I believe
out of everything I think parallel
universes is one of the more kind of
like yeah I I don't see as like this
Fringe idea I just think that right now
we don't have the tools to accurately be
like we're pretty confident this is
going to be a thing oh yeah so you know
it's just the most easiest to understand
and wrap your head around explanation
for something we have no explanation for
so far yeah also the coolest way to
explain it but it's the coolest way to
explain it but also there are just so
many rules of the universe where it just
like it just doesn't make sense you know
um I I think one of one of the biggest
things that I can think of in terms of
like an interesting idea is that you
know in the universe there are certain
let's say constants like the speed of
light or something or like forces that
are like the strong force the weak Force
like constants that we cannot change we
can only get by observing through the
universe it's been proven that if these
constants are changed or tweaked just a
little bit then the universe just
doesn't exist yeah in the way that it
does stars don't form molecules don't
like atoms don't like bond together it's
it's interesting that we live in a place
where so many different coincidences
came to came to be for us to be where we
are today I mean what can I say the Lord
cooked up a banger you know yeah and to
think he just knew and to me to think
that we just won the lotteries of
lotteries of lotteries and and someone
has to yeah someone someone has to or if
we just like to me like what makes more
logical sense is that we are just one
lucky Universe out of [__] so many
where all of these little coincidences
like got put into place that to me seems
more likely than you know than the other
the other option of just we're just the
only on know sometimes the the the
loneliest thoughts are the truest you
know I that's just my theory though
that's a g Theory well we went we
started on the mandala effect quickly
got on something else yeah we really uh
broaden the scope the mandala effect
Theory uh as it goes H it's all right
it's all right I I just I find the
Mandela effect fasc it's very
fascinating concept why it happens and
we've seen it we've observed this
happening in real life but the
conspiracy the that goes along with it
I'm like I don't know yeah yeah the that
I'm not too sure of the Mandela effect
to me comes in the same kind of sphere
as Deja Vu which is like how do you
explain deja uh we've had this kind of
conversation before it's just it's just
a glitch in The Matrix isn't it it's
just like it just to me your brain
programming [__] up yeah yeah I think
it's like your brain thinking that
you've done something and you just
haven't can I say my conspiracy theory
okay go on go on I believe I believe
that maybe we've experienced it like
this moment like in a dream Okay and
like it's been like
ingrained to our subconscious and then
you just have this moment where
something just you think you've
experienced it before and I think to me
maybe I've dreamed it before or some
some kind of similar situation well
there there's also that theory of you
know when they say like right before you
die your life flashes before your eyes
it's the theory that like the life we're
living right now is that
flashback wait what do you wait what do
you mean don't don't [__] do that to
me don't [__] do that to me the life
the life what what we experiencing right
now is the flashback of the life we'
already lived and that explains theja Vu
because we've had because what we're
experiencing right now is the flashback
of our life okay but that if that was
possible that's that'll [__] you up the
days if that if that was because we've
managed to actually uh scient remember
we spoke about it on the podcast the
scientist managed to replicate this
phenomenon in a person so we know this
is a real thing but if if if that were
true how are we able to then replicate
it within are you saying there's
multiple layers of flashbacks within
flashbacks can do you sure oh [__]
hell who knows this is where the
parallel universe the might come as all
right okay all right enough of this [__]